j'ai eu l'impression qu'on en aura lâché
car mal à la fin
la solution elle était avant d'attendre
[Musique]
on en est là hochement se conserve
aujourd'hui on n'est pas à chercher les
pommes jonathan tremblay s'entraîne cinq
fois par semaine
cet enseignant et ancien conseiller
municipal profite de son heure de dîner
pour garder la forme et ce n'est pas
l'hiver qu'il arrête sur une petite
mousse création puis un petit peu de
cardio pour m'assurer de faire le vide
ça me permet de faire le vide de rang du
sport donc pour moi c'était important se
changer les idées parce que la pandémie
est omniprésente et elle a frappé un
grand salon madame et onu comme arrêter
de parler de la double pas arrivé on
décorait donc on a diminué un petit peu
les mesures simples
en quelques semaines le risque de
contracter la coved 19 a
considérablement augmenté au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean on a eu une
période dans lequel on n'avait presque
pas que la première vague il avait été
relativement calme surtout dans des
éclosions
mais la pandémie attendait la population
dans le détour la parution de beaucoup
de cols au début du mois d'octobre
la situation s'est rapidement dégradée
selon le directeur régional de la santé
publique le plus gros gain en nombre de
coques s'est accentué le chat le monde
est très très très des éclosions dans un
ch et celle des à l'hôpital d'alma dans
un cpe
le virus s'est aussi répandu au poste de
police de saguenay 21 cas en quelques
jours on est très sensible au long de
corps à l'intérieur de ville de saguenay
pour la mairesse la coved représente un
véritable casse tête c'est quelqu'un
dans sa propre famille est en contact
avec quelqu'un qui est là qu vide c'est
évident qu'ils risquent de le propager
dans son service pont n'était quelques
contacts au printemps dans une période
très active 3,4 contacter personne qui
était déclarée positive alors qu'on est
monté plus à 7,8 au cours de la période
incombe penser ça a commencé avec la
gorge
en moins de 48 heures il s'est retrouvé
sur un lit d'hôpital il était fiévreux
déshydraté et sa pression trop basse
je les constate et quand ils ont
vraiment branché beaucoup de solitude
s'il opte qui ont été injectés la façon
très rapide dans mon corps
jonathan tremblay devait lutter alors
que le système de santé lui devait
résister tout ce qu'on a eu c'est des
coupures pour la représentante de la fiq
la pandémie est venue fragiliser un
système à la santé précaire
la pandémie a été la goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase pour nous dans le
réseau de la santé mais tout les
problèmes étaient déjà vécu auparavant
malgré tous les efforts toutes les
dénonciations qui ont été faites nous
n'avons jamais été écoutés la conjointe
de jonathan tremblay a aussi été
rattrapé par le virus on sent un peu
coupable d'être malade parce qu'on sait
que ça a un impact sur l'environnement
familial sur les enfants sont les
enfants le corps sur les milieux de
travail les travailleurs de la santé
composent avec cette peur au quotidien
c'est de la détresse c'est du stress et
du découragement c'est très difficile
présentement le moral est toujours à
zéro on sait pas comment on va s'en
sortir on sait pas de quelle façon va
falloir se prend pour continuer aussi à
donner des soins à la clientèle tout en
infectant pas nous mais on est au
scanner de la copine mais il faut faire
un effort tous ensemble parce que cette
bataille là c'est tous ensemble qu'ils
ont peu l'an dernier
jonathan tremblay se remet
tranquillement de cet épisode
ils courent moins vite moins longtemps
il se sent constamment déshydraté
j'espère vraiment qu'on va réussir là
sous peu à la contrer tout ça que le
vaccin fonctionne comment
pour qu'enfin tout le monde doit tous
sens
où